we were well within our rights
protesting he said he added he does not
believe that the flaccid rat can be
repaired flaccidra great bands
hey guys are you looking for the perfect
gift for Mom or another loved one the
Skylight digital photo frame is a sweet
and meaningful gift that will give you a
new way to stay in touch with those you
love it's so simple and fun to use even
if you're not tech savvy and as a
special Mother's Day offer get 10 off up
to 30 off your frame when you go to
skylightframe.com DBT that's to get 10
off up to 30 off your purchase of a
skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com DPT that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash DPT
hey Tony spoken another episode of dumb
people time
take a look at it Jay we're just imagine
a guy going like nope Jake look at it
look Point your face at the thing Jay
everyone in Boston is a walking
dichotomy they're like sweet and
sensitive but they're actually they'll
punch you in the face they're dumb but
they read have you heard you at home but
they were huh you haven't heard my
Boston story yet no oh I can't wait it's
I can't wait it's for us to be at a
festival or something everything you
just described
listen all right don't give it here all
right uh Jay Lawson I'm so happy you're
here first of all let's just take a
moment to speak to the public and say
you were fantastic directing all of the
sketches that we did on the nosebleeds
you did a wonderful job and so much fun
so good so talented and you are one of
the best stand-up comedians we know and
you have a new stand-up special we'll
talk about that later stop bringing it
up I wanted to tease it here's what I'm
going to tease I'm going to tease the
fact that we have a patreon and our
patreon we do unbelievable stories that
are sent in by you guys so this is a
great way to support us as Comedians and
the show [__] that it's a great for them
to support themselves
submit your dumb story and we'll give it
the Deep hearing people's stories from
their lives in their bedrooms or falling
into cactus gardens is makes me not
happy that that happens do you want to
get roasted by us the house
uh you might catch a Greenly over okay
all right let's jump into this right
away we'll talk about Jay's new special
in the second segment this was sent in
by Liz Hagerty at Liz Hagerty love her
what's up Liz what's up Liz sent it in
first I have a little uh notation here
okay for myself Liz send it in first but
it was a link or the link from short
Huey longjacket at yeah underscore good
underscore okay
that link wasn't very good jacket
that link wasn't uh you the once you
sent it it wasn't it didn't have enough
details all right so you got to get that
story with the details and then yeah
good okay I was like how about this link
so I wanted to give both credit oh also
at the end of this story we get to play
a game we haven't played in a very long
time
whose home state did this happen oh I
love it it could be Massachusetts it
could be Illinois it could be Missouri
I would also accept Wisconsin for myself
okay here we go yep
here's that look
inflatable rat no inflatable rat is what
stabbed at aptly named Funeral Home
inflatable rat stabbed at aptly name
someone said murder this inflatable
route they're just like this is supposed
to be a funeral supposed to be classy
why is this rat here I'm gonna take it
down did you know that was the only time
you see inflatable rats an inflatable
rat met its demise in front of a
Springfield Funeral Home on Monday so
the rat is this is the mascot of the
funeral I think it's a blow up out front
yeah that's what I'm saying no it's all
started when a group of Union roofers
were protesting outside of stab funeral
homes wait what it's called stab funeral
the family name right yes yeah David
stabb we only take people who died by
way of knife yes
it's a discount it's a stab discount
how'd you die cancer
before she died
stick the thing in there yeah you get a
little steep okay uh so what's happening
is union workers are protesting they
always use the inflatable rat did you
guys have never seen this this is a
union work I've seen it out here oh it's
a union job yeah well they wanted to
they're the roofers for this uh so they
must have hired is the stab funeral well
I'm just saying it's a business and they
hired non-union roofers oh gotcha so
they're like you dirty rats right the
object or they objected sorry to the
longtime Springfield business using
non-union labor that's right as part of
the protest the inflatable rat which was
intended to call public attention to
companies employing non-union labor
after Rodney the rat after seeing the
rat a woman came out of the funeral home
angry I want to ask you guys she worse
how big do you think this inflatable rat
is how big is it Jay I'm gonna say it's
like it's between 12 and 16 feet pick
one
I said between now you got to pick one
bro all right then I'll say it's then
I'll say it's 10 feet tall okay I think
it is wait did you say between and you
made me make a choice Dan and in that
time I renegotiated with myself and I
said listen 16 is a little out of
control I'm gonna say I'm gonna steal it
I'm gonna say it's 16. okay I'm gonna
say it's 23 feet tall okay it's big one
of you is only one number off okay so
you all get to adjust 15. it's 101 feet
high about 15. what are you wrong with
you one number off no no no no that's
fair he says 15 I say 22. okay
what do you say 11 or 9 okay 11. the rat
is 15 feet
between 12 and 16. this is the wrap
imagine someone in your life has passed
away and this is what you roll up to go
say goodbye to Grandma shame shame shame
on you for getting buried here at the
step first of all the roof looks
terrible non-union labor I mean what do
you want but I mean don't they have to
have like a compressor out there how are
you keeping that thing inflated listen
you don't cut on the roof here's what I
like on the front lawn I like this guy
he was like hey hey are you guys taking
we're protesting it's like I'm not gonna
wave at you who died today who died and
made you rap
John Nix business manager for Roofers
Local uh one one two I support the union
said the woman came running hollering
and screaming and had a knife that was
maybe four to six or seven inches long
that's not enough sounds like he's also
guessing the height of the Rat yeah it's
a knife four five seven yeah I don't
know what she was screaming but she was
screaming and then she stabbed the rat
eight times in the back okay that's on
brand for the funeral part a hundred
percent that's what they do they're
gonna shoot a pellet in that thing no
we're stabbed funeral home
son was mad go out there Barbara and you
stabbed that a little on the nose maybe
we don't go stabs on the nose in the
back how long have they been out there
do they give us that stat Nick says he
wasn't afraid until the woman got done
stabbing the rat I don't know that it
does you want some of this Nikki I
didn't know what she was gonna do with
the knife then he said Nick said she
called the police and the woman returned
to the funeral home enter the woman
Lauren stab oh God a funeral home
director is charged with criminal damage
to property you know what sharp gal but
it's on their property isn't it but
criminal it's their property
you can't protest on someone else's
property right it's probably on just at
the the yeah on the sidewalk yeah yeah
that's right you can't let's see that
Dan let me see it it's horrible yeah
it's on the other side of this I wanted
to say Causeway and then I realized it's
a Boston thing that's the causeway
Causeway problem
um okay kid
Lauren is the daughter of Paul John
stabbed II oh my God Paul John stab is
like PJ stab it could have been a pope
or a cardinal Paul Johnson yeah he's the
funeral home owner who was named on the
banner accompanying the inflatable rat
so it says PJ stab shame shame on you PJ
stab does sound like a TGI Fridays TJ
stabs it's obviously steak because you
get stabbed we're going out a hit go now
what do you want to do kids Dave and
Buster's TGI Fridays or PJ stabs and
also he says hey what you wait BJ stabs
you kidding me also for the kids they
got PBJ PB and JJ stabs you can't get
that anymore
they guys want to make s'mores you can
make s'mores the PJ stabs they put a
light effect bring out the animal you
stab at yourself peanut butter and jelly
steps who wants a raccoon kids do you
think I have the most lowest grade stake
uh PJ's what like a Ponderosa grade
be I've been to Ponderosa yeah Ponderosa
was wonderful it was like seven dollars
for a steak I like that a buffet
Rosemary there once and like we went
there in like 2017 20. if you said you
have to eat 27 pieces of Texas toast to
save your family at Ponderosa I'd be
like my family my family's gonna be safe
do you think you'd throw up though nope
what were you gonna say Ponderosa just
sounds like something on the like Casino
like oh they opened the pond to roast
yeah it does sound like an old but hold
on a second they didn't have the the
second on the the sign on the wrap no no
they just had PJ style so they're
throwing on the guy's dad that's right
yeah
Lauren's the daughter of Paul John stab
and Ringo II the funeral homeowner was
named on the inflatable rat stab when
reached by this publication on Tuesday
said she needed to consult with her
lawyer to see if it was advisable to be
interviewed the newspaper did not
immediately hear back from her yeah no
[__] so you should call the lawyers like
hey let's not don't don't give your
inner don't give your testimony out here
Johnny Nix who either sounds like he's
from possibly Chicago St Louis or Boston
or he runs a prank show Johnny next
TV next and he's done nothing with his
life Johnny Nix is a bar that college
kids don't go to anymore right oh
because we've grown out of it the fights
dude
it's disgusting pictures stick to the
floor at Johnny next I'm not going there
we went there one time and you met a
girl and I always want to go back to
Johnny Johnny and they don't have the
doors got ripped off all the Stalls
remember when that guy went in there and
took a [__] we had to look at her eyes
while he was in there no and he always
pretends he's related to Stevie Nicks
and he's not Johnny Nix okay uh
newspaper didn't hear back from her
Johnny Nick said there was not a funeral
happening at the time of the protest
they got class yeah they're like look
we're not gonna we're gonna mess up
business right well there will be there
will be at some point you know what are
they taking it down in between right we
would never pick at a funeral that's
just something we would never ever do we
were well within our rights protesting
he said he added he does not believe
that the flaccid rat can be repaired
flaccidra great bands sounds like a fish
song the value they don't say the value
of the book came back it's not a balloon
is it it's not a balloon it's a it's in
the same family though right inflatable
directionally inflatable
would you call a pot brownie a joint but
if you blew it into a Ziploc bag you
don't call that a bad stretch right
there what's that yeah you're right you
wouldn't call that a joint no you call
it no that's what did you say if you
blew into a Ziploc bag and closed it
would you call that a balloon I'd say
it's in the same family
what
one got marketed one was just someone
being creative come on what do you want
to call a squirrel a rat with a better
tail and better marketing yes yes I
don't know what we're talking about okay
people love squirrels they hate rap the
value of the big rat balloon is placed
at about how much money
easy 350. 350 350 oh yeah I think it's
like 600 bucks 600 that's a lot of money
I think they're gonna say it's a
thousand dollars it's 22 feet big it's
not 22 feet 15 feet 15 feet I get take
his victory back from the beginning 15
feet the value of the balloon is placed
at about
you said a thousand and you said 350
yeah
five thousand dollars
[Music]
they over inflate
all belong in multiple if not at least
one yeah I always want to be in the
union you are you are you are that's a
good point wait directors not a real you
I mean we're guys will like shiv someone
or create a rat wait so it shouldn't
really protest a funeral yeah shouldn't
this be deflategate more than whatever
Tom Brady went through what did Tom
Brady do nothing we'd never pick at a
funeral the first inflatable rat
was reportedly used by the international
Union of operating engineers local 150
in what year do you guys think the first
I wasn't even going to make this again
yeah because we have we have one more
yes but 1973. that's so funny I was
going to say the 70s too 77. okay uh 81.
89. man these guys are really behind the
time that's according to your photos it
is now becoming ubiquitous means of
protesting the use of non-union labor
employers employers have filed lawsuits
charging that the use of giant
inflatable rats constitutes unlawful
picketing in 2011 the National Labor
Relations Board held that Union use of
an inflatable Monster Rat who knew that
this was such a hot contested it is a
thing it's that a law is against it
right uh is not considered an unlawful
activity when directed at a secondary
employer wouldn't you just say we're
celebrating the Chinese New Year the rat
while picketing
the Paul John stab the second stop the
second the second President of the
funeral home did not immediately respond
to a request for comment so now we will
get out of here on this how old here's
what you guys know it's a funeral home
yeah what state did this the woman named
stab stabbed a rat the woman named stab
again my favorite Johnny
I showed you so I will show you again
yes what state is this guy from because
you now have to play the game who's home
state Massachusetts
Springfield Missouri there is a
Springfield Illinois and there is a
Springfield Massachusetts I've played
this ball Hall of Fame one of the best
places I played that uh is it in
Springfield it's a great this takes
place so yeah what do you think I'd say
Missouri Missouri from Jason I say
Springfield just kidding uh I say
Massachusetts I'm saying Missouri as
well okay
Sky of a Northeastern town
how many stars you think stab has well
I'll tell you oh yeah I can't wait to
look these guys up
this happened in the great state
of Illinois
SNAP has 62 Google reviews for a out of
five stars rating of three stars 3.5
just a stab 4.1 stab in the dark I think
they're doing all doing all right
they're like at four four four four four
point eight
like that with that everything they do
it's great except the roofing but other
than that they're yeah the tops of every
coffin is not great either I once turned
into a funeral procession you haven't
done that and then like then you're in
the middle of it and you're like oh no
and it was like back roads in Upstate
New York and it was like a break in
traffic I'm like oh I guess I can go and
then I go and then like it slows down
and everyone's turning and then all of a
sudden I look behind me and everyone's
got the funeral thing I'm like I'm numb
and this and then it gets the cemetery
and they're like flagging everyone in
and the cops like and I'm like nah I'm
not waiting how do you convey to
somebody with just send my condolences I
I'm so
you know when I duck Graves we would
have to wait for them all to leave and
one time they had a really long service
and uh my boss was like all right start
and I'm like they're still we can still
see their cars they can still yeah I
don't want because you have to get in
the grave yeah I was like I can't do
this all these people still being here
why do you have to get in the grave the
first few inches of dirt that you need
to like packed down so it settles why
would they bury you alive every time
that feels a little because they wanted
me to build my character up just one
finger you get out of it yeah all right
there you go that's Story one when we
come back we're gonna find out about J
special I'm so excited this is dumb
people Town Jay Lassen is with us we'll
be right back
hey gang are you looking for the perfect
gift for Mom or another loved one I'm
gonna let Dan tell you about this
because I have it it's called Skylight
frame I got one for Rosemary she
absolutely loves it it's a great you
know what I love about it too she
doesn't have to do anything first of all
all she has to do is feel loved that's
it included which is huge right because
she's out in Rochelle I'm out here in La
it comes with its own designated email
address and all I just saved it as a
contact and I just email pictures to
Rosemary she gets them she doesn't do
anything other than look at them and see
me and I'm beautiful first of all you
look great Dan and she feels close to
you and she feels like she's up on
what's going on
conversation is her saying I saw that
picture that you sent whether I'm in
Hawaii or on the road or in LA or just
being like Lou this waiter I just
screamed at whatever it is
to be a part of my life through the
Skylight frame they have a 10 inch uh
version they also have a 15 inch version
amazing and then they also have 100
satisfaction guarantee which is like
great because I the little part of me
was like it can Rosemary figure this out
but it's so easy it even says like oh
you have new photos it's a touch screen
she just Taps it she can tap the one she
loves her very cool that you can
designate albums on it and so you can
have an album that's just like holiday
like old family Christmas albums or new
family stuff throughout the holidays and
it'll rotate through November December
if you're crazy October too and you can
have like Christmas or holiday photos
throughout that time of year and then
just go back to the regular photos for
the rest of the year it is by far the
best gift we've ever gotten our mom
Dan's gotten his grandmother it's so
much new way for you to stay in touch
with your loved ones it's simple it's
easy to use sweet and meaningful even if
you're not tech savvy no app or
subscriptions required to send photos
anytime you email them or you can text
them as well it's super super easy it's
a great way to fill it one last thing
I'll say before I tell everybody the
deal they can get here yeah is you get
an you get an email from the email from
Skylight saying you haven't sent one in
a while it's so nice
yeah as a special Mother's Day offer you
can get 10 off up to 30 off your frame
when you go to skylightframe.com DBT
that's right townies you can get 10 off
up to 30 off your purchase of a skylight
frame just go to skylightframe.com
DPT I'll spell it for you yes
k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash DPT
get this gift for your mother or loved
one and they will love you if you want
it you want to win Mother's Day do this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into Jay's awesome special how
you can support it it's out now we'll
get into that is it out now yeah it's
out now it's out now um it came out on
the 19th today's the 25th
um we're super psyched to tell you all
about that uh first before we get to
that next month uh Randy and I will be
middle of the month in Minneapolis
Minnesota Acme Comedy Club it's just one
of the best clubs in the country let's
pack it out yeah and then more shouldn't
be too much snow Yeah more of our dates
at super right now we have a San
Francisco date at Cobbs Comedy Club at
the uh the third weekend in July and
which is great and then we're going to
be in Springfield in the fall
Springfield
Missouri Springfield
and then uh and then we're gonna be in
Ann Arbor the weekend of the 8th and the
9th where my daughter will be at school
and I'm gonna visit her it's going to be
great at the Ann Arbor comedy showcase
superscars.com you can catch me this
weekend in Denver with our good friends
The Growlers yeah go to Daniel
vancouver.com or come to my show every
other Monday at the cats crawl Irene two
and myself host a great show and you can
see great Comics you guys are doing it
we're gonna oh yes yeah you've already
done we just did it yeah but we'll do it
again
and for when the straps up thanks to
everybody who came out to Moontower we
loved seeing all I love doing it and
even though recording this ahead of time
we're going to assume I know what I'm
doing come on Jay Larson has a new
special out Jay tell everybody about it
uh shot it in Austin at the creek in the
cave Lance bangs directed it right uh
very proud of it I self-produced it
funded it did the Whole Thing released
it on my YouTube Jay Larson comedy go
check it out I self-produced my last
special I'm very proud of this one and
uh what's that what's this one called
it's called sounds like Bruce
yeah I love that so uh you know if you
know the wrong number joke people have
accuse me of stealing it for myself
wildest I see tick tocks where people
fight with other people and you can
obviously see like who like the real
comedy fans yeah versus other people
like no I've heard like you shut up so I
saw I cracked that case once and for all
in this special I just did it and the
special and was like it's just so
everyone knows it's mine that's right
it's great this is its own little bit
did you let me ask this did you have fun
as you were telling it in a way do you
feel like this is the best way I've ever
told this or how did you feel as you
were doing it I was just like now I
don't know I mean I just was like yeah
it'd been a long time because I don't
really do it that much anymore but I
wanted to put it down somewhere where I
owned it you know what I mean yeah
and yeah they have the rights and then
you know I did it at the Laugh Factory
and you know they have it and I'm like
no I want this for me that's right right
well and it absolutely should be on the
radio that's what I was gonna say so has
that prevented it from being on serious
and stuff because you did it just no one
has it you know Conan has it on his like
Facebook on his Facebook page is 100 80
million views oh my God and you're just
like oh uh guys can I get any of that
can I get a little piece well so now you
will this is how you do it
special we say this overview please
review share this is Jay Larson is one
of our favorite people in the world and
one of the best countries you'll ever
see uh we say this about the people we
have on this show and the reason why
we're bringing and bringing you
attention to it is so that he can
continue to make yeah this guy should be
making specials all the time and let's
send this a lot of pressure it's a lot
of pressure all the time also when you
comment everyone special let me know
that you came from dumb people Town
always feels great I love it say hey I'm
a townie and I love this special
whatever you want to say give it five
stars give it a thumbs up give it
whatever you can give it and then share
it with your friends that's it so this
is the way of the of the comedy special
these days
uh this came in from Carlene McDermott
Carlene a regular contributor uh here's
the headline this headline on its own
I want to do a movie about this okay
okay man tasked with preserving Japan's
Heritage what that's a series
how do you find this person say it's you
drives into the country's oldest toilet
okay
well is that part of the Heritage well
yeah but he ruined it you got to
preserve it yeah but no tradition is to
drive into the toilet I hope he's like I
created some new Heritage all right here
he's going in the book here we go
whether it's forgetting to flush the
toilet or to wash your hands after a
particularly pungent one we've all had
bathroom accidents of some kind that's
such a long strange make that relatable
what what publication is this from I
don't know the Japanese New York Post uh
but one Japanese man's mishap what does
it say in your link it says it's from
Vice so it's okay all right so they
picked it up from someone one Japanese
man's mishap has done far more damage
than merely violating hygiene standards
the and I'm not going to notice they
couldn't say we've all driven into a
toilet so they had to go we've all had
things happen in the bathroom how can we
make this what do you think relatable to
everybody it's not relatable it's not
relatable this thing is why wouldn't
they just go we've all driven our we've
all had minor accidents driven our car
into whether it was poles or other cars
we had you know slid on ice or make a
joke of this construct who hasn't driven
their car into Japanese oldest toilet
yes none of us well this guy did right
and then you're into the story do I need
to edit this goddamn Vice
thank you we're not going to tell you
how old he is because we'll guess at the
end this Jump Man what age who's the job
is to conserve Japan's cultural heritage
accidentally rammed his car into the
country's oldest toilet on Monday and
broke down its wooden door in the
process I mean he didn't have to keep
going backing up and going into it yeah
that's a little Overkill also do you
need to save the toilet it sounds like
an outhouse yeah that's the oldest
toilet that's right I mean you gotta
save it the man on the inside someone's
in here
yeah just a second
the lengths that I would go to be like
um
hey you became
you became his father he's a good boy
but I'm pooping
and you know it takes me a while to push
I'm
I'm trying to push for my surprise I
gotta stand up to wipe all right come on
and I never get it all I guarded him
he's so guarding all my own sometimes I
stay longer because my knee hurts like
they hurt my boy
the bathroom is located in this 700 year
old well I gave that away Buddhist
temple tofu Gucci
located in my favorite uh Ice Cream
Sandwich all tofu coochies are really
good they're so good job
uh located in Kyoto's prefecture which
is considered Japan's cultural capital
into Japan I have not my wife has she
said
I really want to go I want to just eat
like Subways like down in the subway
Sushi they're like man this is the place
you just come in there I read about this
place in Japan where you it's kind of
like sugar fish here where you have to
eat it as they bring it out because the
rice is warm the fish is cold it's all
fresh come on man that's the one in the
subway so so what I can't remember the
name beards of sushi yeah
Sushi that's it uh all right according
to the local media reports the employee
was visiting the temple on a
work-related trip he wants to go to
conserve it yeah he's writing things off
you're fine you can drive up there
yourself yeah yeah I got that he was
turning his car around in the Temple's
parking lot oh my God but for God he was
in Reverse I think he did this on
purpose exactly you don't forget you're
in room have you ever had this happen
when you're at an intersection you're
the second car and somebody's gone out
too far
yeah and you're like you're still in
Reverse get ready to lay on the horn you
literally just no people normally honk
and I just go I got a camera I mean I
know so I've had people forget you they
start backing up and I had already
started to go so this guy has no camera
I also I do I agree that like sometimes
we think we're the only reason that
Something's Gonna Stop or something will
get cracked or something I was at my
daughter's track meet and a hurdle had
fallen over and they started the race on
the other side they're about to start
the race and all these parents the coach
is like he's also the time keeper he's
like down there right by where the
hurdle and everyone's like coach
Martinez Coach dessertal yeah there's a
her the hurdle's not like all these
people are yelling like there's so many
people yelling the race has started
they're all the way over there the real
race was to see who we created that's
right does it hurdle everyone's yelling
and he just turns around he's like I
know they're over there it's like the
people were so afraid people were afraid
that you're just not gonna know if I
don't stop them
so you're amazing maybe there was
somebody in the temple parking lot two
words I've never said in my life unless
it's like uh your guys Temple Israel
yeah but uh
they that was probably like he sees it
right he knows he knows he's not gonna
bow should I yell at him
this is Japan
why do you think everyone's an idiot
give this guy the benefit of the doubt
sir the Heritage you know you would
shame him and his family do not do that
then put your shoes back on uh he forgot
he's in reverse and pressed down on the
accelerator Japanese newspaper Asahi
shimbun reported so that's who
originally okay they do the that was the
reporter yeah that's really that's the
thing though no one was hurt the extent
of the damage was stunning that's what I
say when I get out of the bathroom am I
right okay that's Clark Brothers
literally not allowed to go into my own
bathroom I have to go in my kid's
bathroom Jason okay if that's how bad it
is uh all right so snacks
Temple's Research Institute told
Japanese newspaper Kyoto shimbun so acai
shinbun reported on this then Kyoto got
it they all jumped in on it
said I'm a Finish Well I got this Temple
aims to restore the bathroom before the
prefectures Autumn foliage lures crowds
but restoration will likely take into
the new year the communal toilet so is
this a museum piece or is this a toilet
that people can use that's the oldest
toilet I'm wondering when they upgrade
it though are they going to put in like
you know like motion like paper towel
racks on like a wooden spoon yeah let's
step it up but what is the oldest toy
look like or do you sit on like Buddha's
lap and then you just [__] just like his
legs a hole a bench with a hole in the
basement that's all it is that's all it
is looks like something you'd find in a
western town that's right yeah or
something you'd find on like the road in
Turkey
so I'm glad I hit it yeah send it a
message the communal toilet known as
tosu when found in Zen temples was built
between what year and what year this is
so if we guess so can the can the game
be we just have to guess a year in that
range if you fall within this range I'm
giving you credit and the range is you
could all get it right the range is 59
years so it's a it's almost 60. read the
sentence again without the numbers when
found in Zen temples was built known as
tosu this this toilet the communal
toilet was built between what year and
what year uh BC or or I'm gonna go last
because I know the answer and I Randy's
electronically the whole the whole
podcast fine you go Japan's look at this
son of a [__] no you go you want me to
go I'm gonna go no I'll go
uh uh 658 A.D 8 30 A.D
I thought we had to give a 59 years
and see if you fall in the range got it
uh
1280.
all right get your answers in one of you
is kind of close okay this was built
between 1333.
[Applause]
1280. I had 59 years to 1280 you get 13
39. and what years 1333 to 1392. thank
you
what do you mean almost right was I in
the range you were out of it by the
amount of years it would take to get
into it right
I don't know what that he just said it
sounded right actually Randy knows I'm
right I know what you're doing you were
as far out of it as the amount of years
it would take you can I explain how I
got my answer yes you told us it was 700
uh 80 years old so I subtracted that
from our current time
I don't want to solve a murder with you
guys
so he listens to details I give Jay
credit I was a federal agent all right
according to the uh the agency of
cultural Affairs the bathroom was built
for aesthetic aesthetic monks and the
house and houses 20 toilets lined up in
two rows sure the latrines are walls
holes in the ground thank you measuring
about how many centimeters deep deep oh
centimeters now centimeters different
that's metric yeah so I'm going to say
all right hold on
come on come on 140. uh a thousand
centimeters
I will be a meter I'll go 200.
they are holes in the ground measuring
about 30 centimeters deep well that's it
it's interesting short they use that
container that doesn't stack I swear to
God that was my how do you get that out
of this I swear on everything Rochelle
that was my first time and your number I
was like there's yeah that's makes more
like man he got close with the years
yeah he's like I gotta knock this down
what if he was like what I just did in
there is worse than me knocking it no
one's using them anymore I don't know if
you said before they're crowds they used
to contain glass containers for monks to
defecate or urinate in and for Hasidic
Jewish men to lay underneath while
people urinated or no you're so full of
it put that on you can put that in there
I was like where's this going left turn
the toilets were separated based on use
the bathroom was built during what's
known as the Muro Machi period I
obviously don't know I would have known
the address you talk about 13 39 to 13
16 13 33 to 13 19 a.m uh of Japan when
the country the Mariachi period signifi
significant cultural developments under
the influence of Zen Buddhism like the
Japanese Arts of tea ceremony and flower
arrangements how old we'll end this on
this was this poor Schmo who backed his
car didn't realize he was in Reverse he
was basically ruined with an artifact
maintaining the culture of this entire
nation instead did they maintain it I
see Japan in this circle can we all say
the age at the same time so we can't get
pinched off of because first you don't
have to pinch I already have my number
51 years old how old are you 37 30. I
don't think anyone under 40 is getting
this job nope watch this man is 62 years
old 62 57 57 30. I said 51 I said 51. 62
51 37 get your answers in this is the
end of story one okay story two coming
up is uh uh Randy it's a story too yeah
yeah oh no Story three coming in yeah
all right this Chomp was 30 years old
thinking about the guy's got a career
going but he's not so far along
it just seems like 2
percent you're gonna give a 2 in charge
[Music]
all the heritage is at the hands of a 30
year old kid I love how right Jay has
been throughout this interview I'm very
good with this stuff I'm a very good
guesser in the third story I'm gonna
give you a little teaser a little give
us a little taste a little tease you can
run away from the police but you better
better damn well do it in style yeah
that's what we're going to see in Story
number three Jay Larson's got a new
special out there called
I love that bit it's so good I love that
it's finally on wax if you want to watch
one of the greatest comedy bits I Randy
and I have said it it is a Master
Classic Master at one point
it was number one on Reddit it sits
nestled among a brilliant rest of the
comedy special and treat yourself to it
watch this damn [__] put YouTube
television on your TV grab some snacks
and and watch it like it's watching on
YouTube there you go all right uh sounds
like Bruce we'll be right back story
number three dumb people Town Jay Larson
don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show I'm
going to take us home okay ready Country
Road this is Story number three sent in
by Matthew McCain at Matthew m c c a n e
Matthew McCain very good interesting did
we meet Edwin McCain yeah we did you did
yeah he was so cool
great dude like amazing and then I heard
his song and I was gonna like record it
and send it to him but I did wonderful
Dude all right Indiana man Indiana man
dressed as Pikachu is this Larry Bird
ran from police on lawnmower
whatever the cops want you for what
you're wearing and you're and then how
you chose to get away from them and then
they found him by using Pokemon go
that's right Rochelle in it they gotta
catch them all Rochdale Indiana Rochdale
officer may have a great sale yeah not
Rochelle Indiana roachdale it's like
Rochelle but it's the Indiana version of
Rochelle Rochdale a Rochdale officer may
have wished he had a Pokeball in order
to help him catch a wild Pikachu but I
mean
do that at all no Pokemon go where you
like did you call a Pokemon joke Pokemon
go is like what adults
what if we filed everybody around sounds
like with this guy was Pokemon gone so
catch a Pikachu spotted uh driving a
lawnmower recklessly through a small
through small Indiana streets on holiday
night you can't even get a good swerve
going yeah so this is on Halloween night
so he had a reason to dress like a pig
also Halloween night I kind of let it
play itself out yeah let it rip a little
bit right yeah it's Halloween it's gonna
be a lot you hear that guy coming a mile
away
sit down more and he's not even going
that fast maybe about three miles an
hour maybe maybe all right so we're
gonna find out how old he is later okay
so this roach Hill citizen who decided
uh to elect trick instead of treat all
right
come on I'm giving
propsuits Witnesses A Night to Remember
uh the police Pursuits Witnesses and I
remember recording Brookshire police
officers were made aware of a man
recklessly driving a modified lawnmower
so this [__] was going fast you know
when they modified
anyway not through the streets of
Rochdale with a trailer in tow while
children dresses ghosts and ghouls proud
the streets in pursuit of normal candy
all right so now so he's got a little
trailer too yeah this guy's about to
turn into a hero or a person I mean Kids
jump on let's go who knows maybe he's
got candy back there picking kids sure
this is the guy you warn everyone do not
go near them know why the cops are
chasing him yet all right so he was
recklessly driving also this that was it
by the way this so he did go out for
Halloween this headline came up in the
article and I just feel like I need to
read it uh Cumberland police detained
goat for questioning I thought that was
good all you need to know about that
yeah a deputy located the erratic
lawnmower I think he was driving
erratically and it's a modified
lawnmower you can't take that on the
street it ain't street legal [__] but
quickly realized it was no ordinary
driver it was the rare lawnmower Pikachu
I actually like that Deputy attempted to
pull the lawnmower over but the man
dresses Pikachu responded with this just
walk with a shock by flipping off the
deputies he sped away as well as he
could does Pikachu have five fingers no
but Pikachu what's interesting about
that yeah you speak on this because that
they can speak but they only speak their
name right yeah
Pikachu responded with a shack flipped
off the deputy and sped away as best as
he could police said the quote pursuit
of the lawnmower Pikachu went for how
long
not miles or time time do I want to
guess distance oh distance how long do
you think it went are we because I've
read this article and the guy knocked
out the varsity football team while he
was in there and he did the line so I
don't know
I was I don't know if they'd do it
because I feel like it's a neighborhood
that they're doing it in blocks or miles
they're doing it in Miles fine I will go
a mile
one mile what do you think God I'm gonna
say 2.7 one half mile
three blocks all right
I can't tell you that before the deputy
broke off the chase due to driving the
lawnmower driving of the lawnmower
becoming more erratic and dangerous even
at one point attempting to hit the
deputy's vehicle this guy is going after
the deputy's vehicles coming out as
Pikachu
pull over man
he's jogging alongside me by the way how
great would it be if he's actually
mowing lawns as he's going yeah that
would be the greatest just one line just
let me corner it off police were able to
identify the suspect beneath the Pikachu
Garb however as Paul Emily from high
school and late and later arrived at his
home where after a brief scuffle so they
figured out who he was let him go he's
Pokemon they've been battling so they
were like this is too erratic this guy's
trans this is my gym isn't that what it
is yeah it's a pokey gym two officers
were able to subdue the man Translate
station they kick the [__] out of him
which he probably kept yelling not fair
that's right no longer in his Pikachu
costume and take him to custody police
say this uh Rochdale citizen faces two
counts of resisting law enforcement
alcohol or drugs were not to believe to
it maybe you just saw him like a candy
High you know what I mean sometimes you
eat too many Mounds take off mouse right
and so uh had been a contributing fact
to the Pikachu dressed man's Antics
according to Rochdale police will end it
on this how old was the lawnmower
erratic modified lawnmower racing during
Halloween scaring people maybe
potentially doing what mowing lawns
ramming police cars with it and then had
to be briefly subdued how old is this
roachdale man in Indiana Pikachu Jay
where would you would you like to go
first Tigger I'm gonna say he's I'm
gonna just steal my number he's between
26 and 32 years old okay and I'm gonna
say he's 28. 28 Daniel what do you think
I will I'm gonna go with my first
thought which is but I feel like it's
older man with the gut go with the gut
should have gone with the centimeters
I'm gonna go 33 years old Jay the age
that Jesus was yeah exactly allegedly
um Not Dead coming back I'm gonna say
19. 19. okay one of you
is exactly right now we get to play the
game who do you think is exactly right
you're gonna stick on 28 no because I
think you would have shown more you
would have been flabbergasted or maybe
I'm greatly really you think I would
have given it up that easily
um
you say it right I say I'm right 19. I'm
right it's 33. okay get your answers in
tallies because this roachdale man is
19 years old you're right Jay you were
right but I changed it and I oh I love
it there you go that is it that is a
story roachdale man going crazy that was
right you were right in me getting
excited at the end so you you your
instinct was correct and then I went you
read him better than you read then he
didn't read me when I did the next thing
so boom I got it all right guys specials
sounds like Bruce it's on YouTube it's
on Jay Larson's YouTube page first of
all subscribe sure if you type in Jay
Larson sounds like Bruce it's gonna come
up am I right yes yeah so just watch it
give it a thumbs up share it please
please please I love it and uh we love
you guys thanks everyone who came out of
moon tower we'll see you guys in
Minneapolis in May Houston this weekend
I'm in Denver are you in Denver this
weekend Denver I'll be in Cincinnati Go
Bananas
Jake hey I love I love it and we love
you guys Skyline Chili and some graters
ice cream I do love it and Montgomery
and Boathouse chips and the fresh uh
barbecue sauce it's so good guys we love
you and no [__] we gotta get back to
work
[Music]